e
e e
Senator Susi we haven't seen you yet but
we've seen a little of your cohorts a
little bit
already
and
okay so this one yeah so I know Concur
and request Comm conference because
there's some money involved
here there was money involved right
that's why we didn't cons I I
I trying to
remember there was um it put the China
Bild into it which Bill we doing now oh
3 okay 1358 okay the China bill yeah
do you really you want to hear why we
have a problem with the China bill or
did you get enough of it when at the
public
hearing okay so repres representa spear
you really want me to go into this uh
you're you're you're batting a thousand
so keep
going my background is electronic
warfare I've worked in electronic
warfare for 15
years this bill is not going to stop
anything in the case of one of the
problems when the title of the bill
which is started me right off if you
wanted if you wanted to say 10 miles
around a military base I thought it was
cute wasn't going to do anything but if
you wanted it you could have it except
that the federal government came out
with a regulation that said if you're
within a 100 miles of a military base
and if you are from a Chinese company
from the mainland China then you have to
ask for permission and then if they
wanted to get the permission you could
if you got the permission then they
should be allowed but our bill would say
no you still couldn't be allowed so now
we're into a lawsuit
situation that was one thing but if you
wanted military uh bases we have two uh
we have the a National Guard and we have
the Communication Center over in uh
where was the Communication Center the
Satellite Communication in New
Boston problem with that is 10 miles
won't stop any interference with any
transmission along that line along along
the satellite line you'd have to be at
least 100 miles away to be able to stop
that companies that work in these kind
of Industries are required to protect
themselves and they do you if you
remember when ba systems put their
facade on the
front they uh that was a security
measure to stop uh to sto uh rece being
able to receive by planting a truck out
in the parking lot uh Doppler
information off the windows okay so
electronic warfare isn't going to really
get affected by this bill it's not going
to stop anything because you can drive a
truck right up to next to something and
take whatever you
want what I'm afraid well we have s s
senta I guess that's the name of the
company
in uh and
Hill that is the agricultural companies
told us agricultural said please don't
do anything to stop them they rely on
them then we have the logging industry
came in and said the Chinese people are
one of their biggest customers mainland
China is one of their biggest customers
and that this bill would stop them from
being able to lease property for where
they put their logs before they shipped
them
overseas then we heard from at least I
did there are Chinese students here if
they live within 10 miles if they rented
an apartment within 10 miles of a
McDonald's or an overhead power line an
overhead power line they would not be
allowed to do
that you say in here that in the bill
that they can't rent property for any
reason at all whether it's a nonprofit
whether it's anything and I'm afraid
that based on the fact that as a result
of the Gaza Israel Gaza
War incidences anti- anti-semitic
attacks have gone up 140% in this state
alone
as a result of covid Asian people of all
different countries have been attacked
all over the country we have hate groups
in this state uh we have the uh I don't
even want to list them because I don't
want to give them that much credit that
are going after people this is putting a
Target on the back of as every
Asian-American that lives in this state
that says this state is taking exception
to you for reasons we have never been we
have never had a problem never had a
problem and we've worked well with these
people over the years and now you want
to ban everything and if it was just a
military basis that'd be one thing but
it's everything every single industry
power line restaurant
everything I I think you went a little
too
far well I will say first of all this
has nothing to do with hate groups has
nothing to do with the uh Gaza or Israel
and I did talk to the AG's office office
the AG's office is actually the one that
helped me write this because he was on
the AG um did an AMX brief on the
Florida bill which is very similar to
this this does not include leases and I
did forward you an email from yes I did
I forwarded the whole committee an email
from the AG's office saying this does
not include leases it does not include
personal individuals purchasing property
it's Only The Entity of the
CCP so when you have one of our biggest
adversaries looking to purchase
land in this
state to
me if you're not looking at the security
aspects of how many um Chinese Nationals
have been coming over the
border which is uh possible terrorism
then I don't know how to explain um your
rationale
frankly we have we
have Congress has actually started
putting together
legislation against the CCP and
purchasing lands so why should we wait
until Congress decides to act and start
doing something on our own and protect
ourselves I I just like to interject for
the Public's benefit that the original
Bill uh wasn't about the CCP it was
about
uh Brewing right and uh so there's
there's actually three bills that we
discussing all as a packet right so one
and there's also uh
influenza no that umle not in the yeah
it's in the title it's not in the bill
it's not in the bill okay so Brewing was
scratched out on one of my piece of
paper I'd just like to off offer that my
wife is from Hong Kong she's Chinese
Heritage and I share the concern that
this might uh you know put a negative
light on American citizens who happen to
be of Chinese descent I I also
acknowledge that this is potentially a
real issue uh and uh I think Congress
would need to act um at a federal level
to really solve this problem so those
are my thoughts if we wait for Congress
to do this we could be waiting a while
they have they've had it the past couple
of years they've just introduced a new
bill it's
bipartisan just like the letter from
Senator Shaheen to Meritt Garland asking
them to look into the CCP owned
properties up in Maine who are marketing
Black Market marijuana
if you wanted to limit the bill
to military bases but I I don't know how
that's going to work or to land being
used for marijuana I wouldn't have any
problems but you're limiting it to
everything you're
right um if if I could just it's not my
committee it's his okay can I yes oh
thank you um the Florida law there
already is already being challenged on
the basis that um it's discriminatory
and it may be a violation of the federal
government Supremacy in um deciding
foreign uh Affairs and they've done an
amicus brief the the New Hampshire
attorney general has done an amicus
brief in favor of it and we have other
we have numerous other states nor North
Dakota has put put a ban in um don't
they have like nuclear nuclear weapons
in parked in North Dakota it's within 10
miles
but that's nuclear weapons we don't have
anything like actually that's not
nuclear weapons the one in North Dakota
is the major Communication Center for um
but you're telling me there's no icbms
in North Dakota I have no idea yeah they
do but the the base that they're talking
about excuse me but the base that
they're talking about is one of the
major Communications for the Air
Force historically this committee
Commerce has Whenever there is a open
court case or or something in question
we we generally wait until that has been
settled before we pass legislation so we
would say to you is that let the the
Florida case play itself out and let's
see what happens um as far as I know
that the People's Republic of China has
not purchased anything in New Hampshire
as yet actually that's not necessarily
true oh really what they bu when I was
talking to the AG's office they actually
had a school that they were looking to
try and purchase Oh the airplane School
the uh what's the what's the school it
was a flight school that no well it was
a school that they were going to use to
teach the um Chinese children and it was
going to so that they could say they
were taught they no they were taught in
New Hampshire when actually they were
doing Zoom calls so that that was
actually turned down but they did try
and purchase it they did try so but it
didn't
happen
yes so uh it's my understanding that uh
the company Volvo is owned by I think
it's Gile is the Chinese parent of Volvo
so does that are we would we be banning
Volvo dealerships from the state and and
second question the bill is very
complicated it has lots of uh items that
are pointed out why not just make it a
blanket ban from for the whole state and
just keep it simple if that's your
intention so those two questions please
that was written by the AG's office and
I trust what he what they put
together
about you have to understand what I said
in the committee is when if it's a
majority owned by the
CCP that that entity is actually owned
by the CCP and they are required by
their
law to do whatever the CCP requires of
them so I don't know how much ownership
they have in it if it's more than
51% that's considered a CCP organization
and they are required by China law to
follow everything that China wants
whether it's spying on us
um
so yep keep going um so the the the last
line says any person who fails to comply
with this section shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor are we potentially making
our constituents criminals if they sell
their house or their building to a CCP
owned company wouldn't they be
responsible for the misdem metor
violation well I'm not sure any of our
residents would want to sell to The
Entity of CCP but this does not include
according to the AG's office if Joe Blow
on Main Street Street and Hamstead
wanted to sell their house as we had
brought up in the um in the committee if
they wanted to set let's say it was a um
parent Chinese parent who had a child
going to exit Philips exitor and they
wanted to purchase there's no ban on
that they are allowed to there would be
no problem with unless that the parents
are employed by the
CCP it's an individual purchase how do
you separate individual purposes if you
just said that it's obligated of every
Chinese citizen to be uh uh controlled
by the CCP it says any company or
development owned or controlled by a
company that is owned in whole or in
part by or is a subsidy subsidiary of a
company owned by the People's Republic
of China they are not owned by um the
sub
CCP the sentence further goes on to say
or whose principal place of business is
located within the people's uh Republic
of China may not have anything to do
with the CCP it may be just whatever but
what it says is the Communist Party
whatever or principal place of business
is located within the People's Republic
of China shall not own lease possess or
exercise and again if you look at the
very first part of that it says any
company or development owns by the CCP
or whose principal place of business is
located I don't see a comma or an
exclamation a person who purchase a home
their business we don't know where their
business is could be anywhere exactly so
if a p if an individual themselves wants
to purchase a home there's no the AG has
no says there's no stopping them from
doing that I I have a comment on that if
I could if you look at what's gone on in
Florida and this points back to what
representative Ammon was saying the
unintended consequence of this is that
people and there was example of this in
the New York Times a young woman uh from
China her parents uh were helping her to
buy a condo she was turned down because
of the fear from the Realtors and and
people selling that they could be in
trouble from the bill so I think that's
an unintended uh consequence that came
up a lot in our hearing from from uh we
heard from somebody on our group who who
was a realy firm um very concerned about
that and again the AG said there there
should be no concern about that well
it's happening in Florida that's that's
this current AG never know the next AG
could we like stop up to the original
underlying Bill and just talk about the
merits of passing that uh on its own yes
we're in support of the underlying Bill
great if we don't have an agreement on
China Bill's dead okay that's that
Bill's dead and and here's the reason
here's suggest is that since you're the
ones that are raising all the concerns
with the language that Senator bzel had
the Attorney General's office right
correct that you identify those concerns
work with the Attorney General's office
and get back to us if the answer is no
then the answer is no okay so here
here's where I'm at with this and that
is we already had a house
bill that was the same subject
matter and the Commerce
Committee unanimously killed the
bill here comes this Bill
unanimously kill the bill as the
chairman I can only say is it would be
incredibly irresponsible for me to
suddenly come come up with something to
make it work when my committee has said
un
unequivocally that we don't want to pass
this kind of
legislation because ofous
arguments oh exactly
it's all a species argument you know why
I don't like this bill because it's
totally xenophobic to me okay and I
always thought Zen it was only China
then I realized said no the word was
supposed to be for anything foreign okay
I learned that in college but no I the
idea that we are going to pick out one
country and say I mean frankly I'm more
worried about Russians than I am about
Chinese but I understand that today
today it's China but
frankly I don't want to say to any New
Hampshire
citizen that you can't go into some deal
you can't do it you got to spend extra
money you got to do something to try to
find out whether the sale is legitimate
whether this is no it's it's just insane
that's ridiculous I personal opinion I
am ridiculous and I think this bill I
think this bill is ridiculous is that on
the mic is that on YouTube yes I I think
the idea of of this kind of legislation
is ridiculous and there's way not
interested in protecting our our
residents I believe our residents are
are very capable of protecting
themselves and they will not sell to the
People's Republic of China period I
remember that when po okay well right
hold me to
it hold me to it but I just don't I
think yes I think the bill is ridiculous
I thought I thought it was ridiculous on
the house side and fortunately my
committee agreed that they they all unan
to the people in North Dakota who are
now living next to that facility no that
facility was Ked out the facility was
kicked out it was by the federal
government and our law would have been
in conflict with that because they said
they can't be within a 100 miles of it
and you're saying only 10
miles so the fact is already we're we're
in a conflict no they weren't kicked out
they couldn't sell the property the
Chinese could not they realized that
they weren't going to be able to um uh
work it so they tried to sell it well
yeah because it couldn't be
there is South Carolina is it the one
isn't that South Carolina where they
sold something to China that was a big
issue did dakot I don't know no no it
was South Carolina didn't they that big
development there this is what they used
against Nikki Haley that that she was
okay about some sale so was that c was
that a
CCC ownership I don't know so n would if
they had that law would that deal nut
gun through when they thought it was
Economic Development to the
state I'm sure they don't feel that way
now that the uh balloon went over their
territory this law is not going to stop
the balloons you know
that I like the balloons that are going
North Korea sending over South Korea so
at any rate yes I I it would be very
unfortunate but I can already see the
headline today is that uh the the Senate
kills a perfectly good important liquor
bill that's housekeeping he got a lots
of good stuff in it let alone dealing
with with uh hooka bars and killed it
because you you were going to fall on
your swords over this Chinese bill that
I do think is ridiculous and I hope they
put it in the newspaper I thought it was
ridiculous if you want to fight the
narratives we'll win hands down every
day on
restricting the Communist Party of China
in owning real estate in New Hampshire
good luck with that okay if if the bill
just did that in a very narrow sense
exactly the words you said it would be
okay that's not what this does and I
just told you if you have concerns with
the bill then come back to us with
amendments that might fix those concerns
the problem I have is how do I prove
that it was a
cccp entity how do I know that I mean
everybody knows that you if you're going
to you know right now H these Hollywood
start when they buy property they have
they have a front that does it they
don't you don't even know who the real
owner is how are we ever going to know
whether the CCC unless they actually
came out and said so if you want the
limit the bill that says is that the
cccp owns is asking to buy a piece of
land in the state of New Hampshire if
that if you want to narrow it down to is
the actual
government would they actually be stupid
enough to do that
so if you asking that is that what you
want the amendment sh I'll strip it all
out I don't want all that crap all I'll
just simply say is the cccp is not
allowed to buy anything in New Hampshire
is that that work for
you one of the problems we have is they
are also one of our largest trading
partners it's and they're trying to
normalize relationships right now we're
stepping in the world of foreign policy
here that we just don't seem to have
any strong basis for getting involved in
we're not foreign policy experts we're
not any of that stuff I we're just
overreaching and we're putting citizens
at
risk so let me ask you Mr President you
you would if we had the bill one L
sentence the cccp is barred from buying
anything in New Hampshire we take that
under consideration
I don't think it works but we'll at
least listen you basically said no I I
I'm saying no I'm I'm bring it up again
so I I I just I asked you to propose
changes okay I have a I have a hard not
here so we have we're putting a a a a a
Target on the back of every Asian person
in this state by saying that they are a
target of this bill just as it has
worked in so many other situations I I'm
not prepared to do
that so I guess
it's we would hope that you guys would
Reed to the to the house uh version of
the bill and that I hear
you this might not be the only one today
or this this week
but we're not ready to to pass this
legislation and like I say is if we find
that the Florida one is upheld and
there's language that does gets upheld
in the courts then then I would probably
feel differently about it but that would
not be this
year right well if if we all agree but
we already have we have one hard no
here I'm a hard no too I'm a hard we're
three hard nuts we're three hard nuts
we're three hard we just not not not
this year someday in the future once we
find out that Chinese are really out to
buy up land in New
England
so you want to schedule another meeting
to take a vote or handle this or how
would you want to how how would you like
to go
forward
Entertain Entertain any positive
suggestions that you might have on
Section 10 and 11 of the bill absent
that
um and and we'd be happy to come back in
a couple of days absent that I don't
how about we set up a study committee to
uh figure out what would be the
appropriate language to have in our
statute I don't think that would satisfy
the
Senate you like study
committees
what there that's what I
I think it's a good
conversation I think it's a good
conversation I I think part of the
problem I'm having is I don't know what
the problem is we're trying to solve it
it sounds like well just kick them all
out are we worried about Espionage are
we worried about pot you know buying up
land to sell IL Black Market pot are we
worried about kids beating up on uh
American buildings which they already do
are we talking about students uh that
whose parents work for some company in
in the in China not being allowed to
live anywhere's near a McDonald's what
you know what what what is the what is
the problem specific problem that we're
trying to address here not some general
thing but a really pointed idea of what
the problem
is I think we are concerned about the
National Security
implications of the Communist Party of
China owning property within a close
proximity of a military base that is the
bottom line concern okay if you do that
and you broaden it out to 100 miles so
it don't conflict with the federal
government I don't think I'd have a
problem with it if you said just those
words I wouldn't have a problem with it
well what I'm suggesting is since you're
the ones that have raised the problem
come back with a proposal that we can
think about work with the Attorney
General's office and we'd be happy to
entertain it you want to write something
up I would write it up 100 miles within
a military base the problem is is that
two of the biggest military braces that
were near don't even belong in the state
well we have one but we don't know what
it is secret secret lost no the uh
Portsmouth naal Shipyard is technically
in Maine but it's in Maine and then and
hansom of course is in Massachusetts
Hans I was talking about the space force
that's the communications you got to be
far away that's that spread Spectrum
it's not going to be that vulnerable you
have to also understand that the
National Guard is not considered um
military
base that's why we had to add the
National Guard in there because it's not
included in the military
base you want to throw in the National
Guard and it would be very interesting
to see if the CCP could buy land around
there
that's well no you've got three or four
different National Guard uh facilities
around the country and if you're going
to do 100 miles around you've pretty
much covered the whole
state fine you want you want to protect
against military
uh organizations but it has to be the
same way the feds do they can't conflict
with FEDS they ask for permission if
they get the permission because the the
business is a gol business because
that's what somebody wants to invest
in something different yeah what happens
they want to buy a golf course and they
do you're G to be worried about that the
cctp owning a golf
course okay it's too bad um I feel sorry
for the commission and I feel sorry that
they were trying to solve this hookah
problem
but we're we're not
no you want to do something
no sorry
okay the next here right
y
e
e e
okay um since we have these other two
issues rescheduled for another time
unless you have changed your heart any
of
this you guys have any feelings one way
or the other and where we're going with
them well I think um
maybe you're very sensitive guy very yes
he is um since we're working on 354 and
555 why don't we um recess this until we
get a solution on those yeah that's fine
okay GL we had to start so uh uh so
those
are one we did uh the fourth and is the
other one on the fifth 4
407 which one's 4 oh that's
the that's the ambulance one so the but
the two the two bills we just did 354
and
555 right so we and can we do Thursday
morning what did we do five five yeah we
got yeah Thursday morning Thursday
morning or Wednesday no I have 55 is
Wednesday morning I know but Senator
avar is going to be away on Wednesday so
so you want to do Senate Bill
555 uh on the
5th yeah that's Wednesday no we got 555
is GNA be tomorrow tomorrow okay and
3:54 is actually tomorrow as well at
11:30 so we'll have we'll have hopefully
those settled had settled um okay so
when do when do you want to take up this
one push it to Wednesday okay uh I just
got the clue that I can do it without
him on Wednesday if you
want and Wednesday we
have uh I have 10 we did this one at 11:
you want to do this at
11:30 uh I or or is that the ambulance I
have one at 11: and one at noon right I
have noon also I think we're both on
that one why don't we do one you one 1
pm
okay and this is June
5th and this is House
Bill
1380 what's the number 1380 1380 okay at
one
okay in this room what that in this room
in this room okay
y I'll call 1381 p.m.
y okay so we are now in recess until
June 5th at 1 pm in this room awesome
thank